of the sell Point accounting for the
virtual privacy thank you so much thank
you all for coming
um yeah so this is Joint work with all
of these fine folks uh most of whom are
in the room I guess shahab is on zoom
and Faye's not here but everybody else
is around
um okay so as as I am in my heart a true
information theorist I am contractually
obligated to start my talk with this guy
um so so I want to take inspiration from
Shannon in a specific way which is so
what did Shannon do when he was looking
at the noisy Channel problem we start
with it started with a channel model
given by this conditional distribution
and he came up with this thing that we
call the channel capacity right
and the channel capacity is great
because first of all it has this really
specific operational meaning right
asymptotically the number of bits per
Channel use that you can send across the
channel
but the other nice thing about it is
that it's one number
right it's one number that tells you
something really important about the
channel and so there's a sense in which
once you have this sort of single single
statistic you can go back and think
about what what the channel should be
right it's like once you know that
capacity is what you want to have then
you can go and think about how to like
uh invest in your channel you know how
should you how should you change your
channel to to to make it better
um so there's the sort of coupling here
and the coupling is allowed by the fact
that this is like a relatively simple
thing
but I want to make that analogy uh with
these two problems in differential
privacy
um so one of them is mechanism Design
This is like what kind of noise should
we add
uh and this is in a way it's sort of
analogous to the channel model right and
here uh we have even more control
because we basically get to make up the
channel right we can add whatever noise
we want to
um and the other problem is accounting
so of course we talked about this and
and also uh Mario and this is like you
know given an algorithm what is the how
much privacy do you get and so I want to
say this is kind of like the channel
capacity right it's some way of
extracting information from the noise
distribution and say okay like how good
is your app
so there's lots of work on both of these
uh problems I'm sure I'm failing to to
list things here
um but I want to kind of make this point
these things are sort of inherently
coupled
um okay so I think by now I probably
don't need to spend too much time on
this definition
um but I I do want to I was just
observing that I think the talks in the
morning we've coordinated to make sure
that our notations are all slightly
different
um so so I believe that a mechanism is a
conditional distribution not a function
but we can argue about that later
um but then you know this is the same
same old definition of Epsilon Delta DP
then but I'm sure you you all you all
know by now
um
so yeah so you can I sort of think about
it as this way like you know you can
have a specific Epsilon and Delta pair
that you're interested in but really for
a given mechanism there's some kind of
Continuum of Epsilon Delta pairs which
you might plot uh like this where here's
Epsilon and Delta media log scale
but look that looks like this you'll see
some actual curves later on in the top
um okay so there's lots of equivalent
ways you can write this
um this is actually essentially the same
as the hockey stick the Divergence that
shahab and Mario talked about
um so here it's equivalent to say a
mechanism of Epsilon Delta DP if it
satisfies this condition or we have this
sort of expectation involving this
variable l so L is what we call the
Privacy loss random variable and it's
essentially log of the density between
uh the mechanism for for two neighboring
data sets
so this um this expectation quantity is
kind of the key way of extracting Delta
for at least for given Epsilon so I'm
going to call this thing Delta L of
Epsilon and it'll show up a bunch of
times in the talk
okay so um in order to get into this I
want to sort of make a distinction
between non-adaptive mechanisms and
adaptive mechanisms so but the
non-adaptive mechanism what you're doing
is you have some data set and you apply
a bunch of sort of separate mechanisms
over time so this is like each one is a
different composition of your of your of
your privacy and each one is sort of
uncoupled to the other ones right so
when you apply the second mechis and it
doesn't depend on the output
this is not adaptive because you don't
you don't use that information
um and you can see that if you have
non-adaptive mechanisms and the Privacy
lost random variable is going to
decompose into a sum where each each of
these things is the variable
corresponding to one of the mechanisms
so we have non-adaptive mechanisms it's
easier to deal with because everything's
independent
um on the other hand if you have an
Adaptive mechanism where when you apply
your second uh mechanism you are ex
using what came out of the first one and
the third one depends on the first two
and so forth
um so obviously this is the more
practical regime if you're training a
machine learning model or something and
each one of these things is calculating
a gradient and then adding noise to it
the gradient depends on where you are
which depends on the previous output so
really practical a very useful regime at
least is adaptive and we have adaptive
mechanisms the Privacy loss random
variable isn't going to be independent
in the same way
um but it turns out you can kind of
assume it's independent so there's this
nice result by by dong at all which I'm
kind of vaguely summarizing here which
is that it was and what it says is that
even if you have adaptive mechanisms
there's a way to come up with
independent
privacy loss random variables such that
you essentially can treat it as if
they're non-adaptive so you get you have
the same Delta L function uh that I
showed in the previous slide with the
expectation of L where L is a sum of
these
so even though with the adapt adaptive
mechanisms your individual privacy loss
variables aren't independent let's just
assume that they are and you can we can
use this result
as far as I know every privacy
accountant is essentially doing a
version of this so if you want if you
want to really deal with the dependence
between these variables
um it's very difficult because you have
to understand kind of how exactly the
previous outputs are being used in in
each step so so we're not doing that
we're just assuming everything's in
effect
so as I said there's lots of privacy
accounts um I've kind of divided them
into two groups which I'm calling order
one methods and and a little Omega one
methods so what I mean is the dependence
on the number of compositions
so this stuff
um
it's independent of a number of
compositions so for any number of
compositions it's still sort of a
constant the amount of time it takes to
compute this thing doesn't change
whereas here is the number of
compositions increases the amount of
time it takes to compute it in also
increases
um so over here we have stuff like
random DP moments accountant also
gaussian DP I'll talk more about that
um later uh and then over here there's
all there's things based on the fft
um another algorithm called connect the
dots uh and so I guess I want to say
that I'm really focusing over here and
again this goes back to this inspiration
from Shannon that if you have an order
one method that somehow it it has to be
based on just a few maybe one or two
numbers that you extract out of your
mechanism that tell you the key things
about how that mechanism performs
and and that's that be that ability to
extract inside is kind of what's going
to connected to the mechanism design
problem
uh oh I should say
um so this talk is really the main focus
of this talk is Epsilon Delta DP so so
all so many DP will kind of come up but
it's really everything is sort of in
service of Epsilon Delta at least the
purpose of of this talk
um okay so let me tell you about some of
some of these things so I'm going to
start with gaussian differential privacy
um and the inside of graphene gaussian
differential privacy in my mind is okay
so you have this privacy last variable
which is a sum of a bunch of independent
things
um so the central limit theorem tells
you that this thing is going to be
roughly Galaxy
so if you can write the Delta as this
expectation of with as a of this
function of L well then you're going to
get a pretty good approximation by just
replacing L by a gaussian so here N is a
gaussian random variable with the same
expectation and variance is that
this is kind of what the central limit
theorem would tell you to do and like
this thing is fairly easy to compute
um so so this is like a pretty good
approximation for for for for for the
Privacy that you get
um we can also show uh as far as I know
this has this exact thing hasn't been
proven previous to that
um so here uh
this is Epsilon for a given Delta as
opposed to Delta for a given Epsilon
um and so this is saying that as as the
limit as the number of compositions goes
to Infinity Epsilon looks like the
expected value of the Privacy loss
variable and some additional term having
to do with the variance and so this is
like a the inverse gaussian CDF so Gauss
this is the gaussian approximation is
coming up in here
um so if you look at these things in
terms of the number of compositions so n
is the number of compositions this thing
is order n and this thing is order root
n so the kind of most significant
element of this is this first term
right so if if you're doing a whole
bunch of compositions so if you're
training your machine learning algorithm
with tens of thousands of iterations or
more
um the the N is gigantic so the by far
the dominating thing is that first term
and so again if you could have if you
want to connect this back to how should
we design the mechanism
um so to first order we should minimize
just this expectation of of L
and in fact the expectation of L is just
the KL Divergence between between the
the the the two the two output
distributions
so in some sense this is like a capacity
if you like of the Privacy problem
um because as the
n as in the sort of asymptotic little
mini composition regime that's the
that's the sort of dominating term
so what we can do is we can optimize for
that that KL Divergence
so I'm going to assume that we're in a
regime where our Mech each individual
composition looks like this so we have
our data set we apply some function to
it uh which is like it could be like
calculating the gradient
um and then we add some noise
so so hero assuming this noise is kind
of independent of everything else
um so it could be gaussian noise but
maybe gaussian isn't all right
um and so you can sort of work out okay
what forgiven a noise the the KL
diversions that you want is is looks
like this so if you want to find the
best noise we should minimize that thing
subject to maybe some cost of constraint
so this this cost constraint could be
for example quadratic cost you can plug
in other things there as well
um so the first time I saw this
optimization problem uh I find it looked
a lot like uh rate Distortion kind of
problems information Theory so I assume
that the answer would be gaussian
but it's actually not it's a little it's
sort of different and important way
because this isn't the mutual
information this is a kale Divergence
between two distributions which are kind
of shifted by some sensitivity parameter
um so it seems like even for quadratic
costs this has no close form solution uh
as far as we were able to come up with
um and it's an infinite dimensional
optimization problem although it is
convex uh so we were able to kind of
Solve IT numerically just by by applying
a sort of quantization scheme and what
we what we find is that the the sort of
solution to this has this really funky
shape right question
oh so so we just we need something here
because if you try to minimize this
thing subject to nothing you can get
infinite privacy but terrible utility
right so we have some this column cost
function just sort of a proxy for a
utility
uh and so he for for this shape I'm
assuming a quadratic
um so we solved this thing and we get
this funky funky shape which uh because
some of us are from Arizona we thought
it looked like a cactus
uh so they call this in the cactus
mechanism
um and it's sort of in this sense sort
of asymptotically optimal this is the
distribution for for scalar uh so for
scalar query so this is a scalar
distribution
um so it's definitely not gaussian
um which means it's Ewing better than
gaussian at least in terms of the scale
Divergence
so the only problem with this is that
this is all derived from this gaussian
approximation and in fact this thing is
only derived from the first term in the
gaussian approximation we didn't even
use the variance right
um and the calcium approximation could
be pretty good but it can be inaccurate
If you're sort of in the moderate
composition regime and the reason for
this is because there are large
deviation effects that are important
right Delta is going to be really small
so you're in this regime where you're
interested in probabilities like way on
the tail of the distribution which is
the large deviation error so the
gaussian the sort of the central limit
limit theorem doesn't talk about large
deviation so we need a sort of slightly
different tool to get a more accurate
thing and what's what's going to become
the saddle point account as a way of
doing that it's a way of kind of
tweaking this this gaussian
approximation a little bit so that we
get kind of good effects for the large
deviation regime as as well as a sort of
gaussian approximation
so what we're going to do is uh
exponential tilting
uh so this is a very simple idea you
have some random variable L with some
PDF and we're going to come up with a
tilted version of that variable which
I'm calling L tilde we have this tilting
parameter T
um right you just take the PDF multiply
it by an exponential in T and then find
a constant to make sure that it's
normalized
so some picture like this so like the
yellow thing is the original
distribution and you apply the still
thing and you just sort of change the
shape a little bit if you think about
this as like an important standpoint
you can write this um like the the
normalizing constant in terms of the
cumulative generating function of your
variable L
um and once you and when you do this you
can you can do all sorts of Tricks so
for example if you have a bunch of if L
is a sum of a bunch of things that are
independent then the Tilted version is a
sum of a bunch of the same tilting
applied to each individual variable and
these are again independent
um also any expectation of L can be
Rewritten in terms of the Tilted
variable it's very simple just to kind
of put in an exponential and take it out
and then you have this very simple form
so we can apply this to the Privacy
calculation
so again here's our Delta L function
which is his expectation of a function
of an l and so if you just apply this to
get to get something in terms of the
tilting variable it looks like this
again here's this cumulent generating
function popping out and now it's an
expectation and L tilde but there's just
this additional exponential term in t
uh so we can do one more movement where
I've just sort of pulled out an another
e to the minus t Epsilon and the T
Epsilon showed up and there
and so this is an equivalent way of
saying it
um now this expectation here it's pretty
easy to see this thing is always less
than or equal to one because this sort
of
so this positive part thing is only
non-zero when L tilde is greater than
Epsilon and so if l01 is greater than
Epsilon then this term is less than one
and so is this term so the whole thing
is always less than one
um and if you just do that straight
bound I'm just like okay that's up
around this thing by one this gives you
a privacy account this is in fact the
moment technology so this is this is
kind of I mean the first one or an early
privacy accountant
um which is which is very good and it
looks like this you just you just take
this upper bound to be one and then you
can also minimize over T to find the
sort of the best the best tilting print
right
um so you solve this by the derivative
of the cumulative generating function
should be zero should be Epsilon
so I should say the cumulant generating
function is essentially the same as the
Rainy Divergence right T is like I think
T is like Alpha plus one
so this is this is very this is more or
less talking about this morning
um okay but you know this taking this to
be less than or equal the one is a is a
fairly crude bound we can do a little
better
um so if we just combine these two ideas
so we first start with this formula for
for Delta in terms of this tilted
variable L and let's just replace L with
a gaussian of the same expectation there
like I said so now we have n tilde which
has the same which is the gaussian same
expectation and variance as L tilde
and these by the way these numbers you
can very easily get also from the
cumulant generating function for for the
Privacy loss variable
so this is this is sort of combining
both the kind of large deviation effect
via the exponential tilting as well as
this sort of central limit kind of
approximate
so this um is why I'm calling Saddle
Point number one so this is the first of
the style Point
um quantities so there's another one
coming up this is called we call this
spclt Center limit theorem
and in fact we can we can prove a hard
uh hard bound on this so it's a hard
sort of error back on so this is about
on the difference between the sort of
the true value of delta and this and
this Saddle Point approximation
um is given by this complicated formula
that I'm not going to talk about uh we
can prove this via berryessing theorem
um and by the way the reason this is
called the saddle point of approximation
is not should not be clear yet I'll
explain that in a minute
um
okay so so this is this is great and
this is going to sort of be a correction
on the moments accountant if you like uh
so the only thing that's kind of weird
here is like okay so how should we
choose t t is this tilting parameter
so you can kind of you know this bound
applies for any T so you can you can
just make up how you choose T
um but it turns out there's a kind of uh
mathematically inspired specific way to
see that seems to be pretty good so let
me try to tell you about that
so here's a different way of thinking
about the situation
um this is going to be a kind of Fourier
version of this analysis
um so this is uh the Percival plant
trail identity which says if you have
some integral of the product of two
functions you can replace them with the
Fourier transforms and you get the same
track very very basic idea okay so we
can apply that idea to this expectation
so this is just rewriting the
expectation as an integral
let's do the exponential tilting things
all that means is I multiply by e to the
TX and I and then e to the minus takes
and then these are my two functions so
the stuff over here is going to be like
f and the stuff over here is going to be
like G
and I apply parcellville plantarel and I
get this so so this stuff is essentially
the Fourier transform of this and then
this thing involving the cumulent
generating function evaluated at this
complex argument is the human generating
function of this so so the the tilting
parameter T is in there still
I can write in a slightly different way
where I take an integral over Z where Z
is this complex number and basically
what's happening is I'm integrating in
the complex plane along this line right
and the the exact line I pick is T is
this based on t
what's interesting here is that uh the
value of this integral act doesn't
depend on Q it doesn't matter exactly
what trajectory you take on the complex
claim which is kind of something we
should not be surprised by from complex
analysis
um
so what this but so there's a sort of
equivalence between the trajectory
you're taking in the complex plane and
this something parameter
okay and we can also rewrite this by
kind of shoving everything up in the
exponent where we have this just e to
the F Epsilon or F Epsilon has all these
terms
so now we've kind of converted
this problem of calculating Delta into
the calculating this this complex
integral
now there's a trick uh that's used all
the time in in statistics and even
physics where it's called polymethodist
Zen which could be used to approximate
integrals like this so how does that
work
um okay so we have this integral complex
integral
um so what we do is we find this thing
called the saddle saddle point is a real
number T naught that minimizes these
this function up in the exponent so you
can very
quickly determine this function is
convex and its derivatives given by
these things you just solve this this
equation to find the saddle point P
naught
um this is actually very similar to the
moment it's a counting condition which
was just KL Prime equals Epsilon so
these are these sort of extra terms
showing up here
so why am I calling this Saddle Point
um because it really is a saddle point
so if you think about this F Epsilon
thing in the complex plane
um along the real axis it's kind of a
minimum and along the imaginary axis
it's a maximum so the saddle point is is
this point here so it's this is because
because it is the T naught the minimize
the system
and then what you can do is you can just
apply a second order Taylor Taylor
approximation to F Epsilon around this
saddle point and then you can evaluate
this integral and you end up with this
term like
so this thing calling Saddle Point
number two so this is the second kind of
approximation based on on on this idea
so this one is sp MSD for Methodist
steepest descent
of gaussianity when you're taking the
second second or Taylor expansion right
you have that kind of gaussian looking
integral here
okay so now we have these two
approximations based on versions of the
saddle point
um we have the first one I talked about
spclt and the second one is spmsd
um which look kind of different
um but actually so they're having more
in common than you might think
um first of all they each have a t in
them and what we're going to do is just
use the saddle point value for for team
both of them
we can also show is they have a
connection
um theoretically which looks like this
so you can the CLT is upper bounded by
this which looks a lot like the MST msd1
but not quite because here we have K
instead of f in the denominator but like
f is mostly driven by K so they're not
too different
but we also see empirically is that
these two approximations are usually
very close
um they have some pluses and minuses
like the with this one we were able to
prove this sort of hard error bound uh
whereas with this one we weren't but
it's it's also sort of simpler as as an
expression
um the other thing about the this method
is that you can actually get even more
accurate approximations so if you kind
of pick more and more terms in your
pillar expansion uh you can get a
sequence of approximations that get more
and more accurate but get also some more
complicated I'm not gonna
okay so so here are some here's some
numerical results so this is for
sub-sample calcium mechanism
um okay so there's a bunch of lines here
so the dash white lines are the bounds
from the spcl T so this is the error
bound Plus or plus or minus
um the red is the moment's accountant uh
this yellow one is prv which is which is
the Gopi at all version of the fft uh
accountant and then this one is a can
connect the dot algorithm
um so for this
uh so again and here's like this is
Epsilon and Delta right so
um
okay so so for the I guess the SP CLT
and the prv accountants have an upper
and a lower bound
right so maybe the upper bound is the
more useful one but they do also give
you a lower bound
um the other thing about actually both
of these two accountants which are kind
of numerical accountants is you can give
them a desired accuracy and they'll
they'll give you they you can make them
more accurate just by sort of running it
for longer so we've plotted them for a
specific accuracy and you can see that's
why kind of this thing at some point
stops being a good approximation because
there's nothing wrong with it it's just
like it we only asked for that much of
much accuracy if you want to be more
accurate you could make it that way
um and the same kind of thing for The
Connect the Dots algorithm
I should say that getting these
numerical accountants to be super
accurate for really small values of
Delta like down here in the 10 to the
minus 20 range that's that seems to be
pretty hard
um because you start to run into
numerical uh numerical accuracy problems
um so one nice thing about the saddle
point is that it basically gives you
this like really far large deviation
regime very easily moments accountant is
also doing fine for the same reason
uh so maybe Delta equals 10 to minus 20
is an impractical regime but at least in
principle we can we can get there
here's another plot uh showing how well
these things do so so this is
for uh for fixed mechanism
um and the fixed Delta where we're
varying the number of the number of
compositions and then I'm plotting
relative error in epsilon so we were
able to compute a kind of round truth
Epsilon and this is the relative error
um so what you see is both the sort of
gaussian approximation and moments
accountant are not doing great the spclt
bounds are better but what's actually
interesting is that the spclt
approximation itself so this is the kind
of the middle of the bounds is actually
way better than the bounds or indicating
so it seems like the uh the bounds are
pretty loose
uh this Airbound is pretty loose the
other thing so we have I have three
versions of the spmsd I said you can get
kind of more and more accurate
approximation so k equals one two three
over three versions of this Taylor
expansion
um so that's k equals one so you see
it's kind of roughly similar to the CLT
approximation
um k equals two is actually also very
similar but k equals three gets
dramatically better that's the best one
here so in terms of just pure accuracy
this one this one's super good
okay so in the last few minutes I want
to get back to mechanisms
a little bit so I argued that if you
have one of these order one accountants
it can give me the site on the best
mechanism so let's let's sort of get
back to that
okay so again we're in this setup where
we want to find the best noise in
principle you can write down this
optimization problem
um where you'd like to minimize some
cost for the noise subject to a
constraint on the actual saddle
so this is the saddle point number
um here I guess I've I've swapped I put
the cost and the objective instead of
the constraint but it doesn't really
matter right this is a very similar kind
of idea to the the cat we came out with
him
the practice mechanism
so this is a little harder because this
is now a non-convex problem because the
the CLT expression is is sort of more
more complex it's not necessarily Prime
of X
um
we would also like to solve this for a
multi-dimensional noise so if you're
training a machine learning model or
something you have to add not just a
scalar but cut some kind of vector noise
so we're going to assume that our noise
distribution is rotationally symmetric
and again we can apply we can sort of
apply some kind of quantization and then
just do gradient descent to try to
optimize this this mechanism
um and the gradients are kind of
easy-ish to compute and the reason that
they are is again because this thing
only depends on a few numbers right so
this is going back to this this inside
I'm trying to get from Shannon that like
because it's only a few numbers you only
need to worry about those numbers in
terms of your magnets
um so here's what some of these uh
Saddle Point optimize mechanism look
like so here um optimizing for these
parameters and what you can see is you
the nice thing about the saddle point
optimization is that you can dial in
exactly what you're interested so this
is like you pick your Epsilon Delta you
pick your number of compositions you
pick your sub sampling rate and it'll
give the principle give you back a
mechanism uh so this is the distribution
of just the radius of the distribution
um so the yellow is the optimized One
the red is the it's just gaussian
um you can see they're not that
different but this is sort of reshaping
this thing a little bit
um
and then I guess this is what the
17-dimensional noise the reason I think
we picked 17 dimensional is because
we're going to apply this to train a
simple machine learning model uh so this
is on the new adult data set uh we're
just doing logistic regression so it has
to have a few parameters so we're going
to add this noise uh we're basically
doing dpsgd except with one of two
different noise distributions uh here
Delta is always 10 to the minus five and
when I'm plotting is Epsilon versus
accuracy so there's for each of these
two noise noises we ran at for a certain
number of compositions and more
compositions you go the higher Epsilon
gets but also the accuracy gets better
and so these two we picked the gaussian
to have the same variance per Dimension
as the spa optimized ones they have the
same variance
um and you can see you get
what's really better about the optimize
it's a little better uh you know it's
privacy is better it's not that not just
that it's accuracy is better it's mostly
better because the Privacy is better not
because the accuracy is better
um but you see for you know for a given
desired level of accuracy you can get
like maybe one Epsilon or 0.8 Epsilon
so principle this this seems like it it
it it it it could be good
um okay so let me just conclude so again
the kind of main point I'm trying to
make is this is coupling between
mechanism design and privacy accounting
uh I talked about the saddlepoint
accountant which is simple and accurate
even for very small Epsilon
um we can and then you can kind of use
this insight to optimize mechanisms
either from KL Divergence which was this
thing called Cactus mechanism or from
the saddle point itself
um and the optimized mechanisms seem to
outperform gaussian at least in these
preliminary experiments and I should
then emphasize that that last slide is
this is very much ongoing work
um so yeah we're still trying to
understand exactly how much better you
can get if you if you optimize a
mechanism
okay so there's a cactus and there's the
saddle um and there's some archive cases
so thanks very much
[Applause]
questions
why you might prefer to add noise like
seven noise rather than six noise do you
have an intuition on this
um yeah so so this is a great question
um and
to answer the question by agreeing with
you
um so that there is a in addition to it
being weird it's not a good idea from a
different reason which is that the
accounting is actually really hard
because you don't know exactly what
shift is the worst case shift
um but the the way if you remember back
when I talked about this
authorization problem it does consider
that it's I mean it maximizes over all
possible shifts so it's sort of
accounting for that in that sense we
know that this non-monetized mechanism
is going to beat any monatomic mechanism
if you could account for it the big if
but okay so your real question is why is
it not monotonic
and the answer is I have no idea this is
what the optimization problem is
um I guess you know why okay
why should it be optimal right like or I
shouldn't be modified so did you have a
signal did you empirically or or
theoretically have a statement that it's
better than any monotonic uh
distribution
yeah we do know that theoretically
um because you can
um you
um
yeah because you can if you make the
quantization and bins kind of small
enough you can get arbitrarily close to
the true optimal
um and you can optimize with
without a monotonicity constraint or
with and you see this
so you can also optimize what the
monitor State this way in which case
it'll be monotonic but it's still kind
of stuff
yeah so I I wish I had a better answer
for like why it is but it just seems to
be a
best
um there is some kind of competition
cost associated with it right I mean
comparing that Spa to a gaussian
gaussian is that simple to run and I
mean how do you how does it scale yeah
so I think when it comes to when you're
actually training it so if you've once
you've already found the magnetism
um yeah it's a little harder to sample
from one of these things but I don't I
don't think that's a big deal I I don't
think the the you know computational
time of printing a model is dominated by
generating the distribution right uh so
even this is not going to take very long
the the thing that does take a while is
solving an application
um so and if you really you know as I
said you kind of dial in exactly what
you want to do and then the downside of
that is that every time you want to run
this with different type of parameters
you have to optimize
um but I guess I would argue that if
your ultimate goal is privacy rather
than just computational efficiency right
if you if you're fitting a machine
learning model without privacy then what
you care about is you want to solve it
quickly you want to get a good solution
but if you care about privacy it seems
to me you should be willing to give up
some computational efficiency for that
so if you can get one Epsilon better for
the same accuracy but it you spend five
minutes running an operation problem
s
if you don't have any closed form
Solutions anymore right let me choose no
yeah uh there um yeah but we have some
other work different position would be a
whole other thought that has some
personal things but yeah all this stuff
I talk about here is
how easy is it to sample I mean they
look like gaussian but they're not
gaussians what you're saying yeah
um are you sure you can sample from the
secure like in a way that
really satisfies the key the
cryptographically secure fashion or not
um I think so I mean I I if you believe
that uh any non-random number that's
coming out of a computer is random then
um maybe it isn't uh but
it's you know it's uh it's not that hard
uh as I said it's harder than a gaussian
but you know I mean how do you how does
the computer sample from a calcium does
anybody know
um like it it's that's been optimized
because everybody wants gaussians and so
you put there are ways you can make this
thing more efficient but I mean I think
what you're really asking is can you be
sure you're sampling from the brightness
um and you have to be careful about that
to a certain extent but you know you we
have you have a bunch of bins and
there's a probability to be thin and
within each event you want to there's a
it's a continuous distribution within
the bid so you want to choose a you know
uniformly choose a radius or something
that's it but as long as you do that I
think you're I think you're fine
the cactus
um do you have any sense of how much
better it is than I guess yeah we didn't
show up a pairs of the cactus against
the yeah so uh yeah I don't I don't know
that plot so one um
I don't have a good like theoretical
notion of it
um one thing that's interesting is as
the noise variance gets bigger the gap
between them gets smaller
um so this is actually another line of
work that
I don't have to talk about but like as
as the noise variance goes to Infinity
they become the same effect so there is
so it's it's much better at small
variants
offline let's take all the speakers
[Applause]
foreign